[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
c'est quelqu'un qui m'a demandé si je
n'ai pas le permis de conduire jim
permis international de moteurs de
voitures d'hélicoptères d'avions je peux
tout piloté m'amener sous marin
s'est trompé ou il se trompait
[Musique]
on va voir si l'application c'est du
mensonge ou pas vas-y vas-y aux
attentes en bas on va refaire va voir on
va voir confirmation ou pas non
on a une nouvelle salle de bains mais
est ce que vous vouliez une blague
c'est joli mais c'est joli à voir
les tomates
mais est-ce que vous foulez la blague du
siècle regardez-moi ça on a une belle
paroisse sauf que on a un léger souci de
de 20 autres voiliers rencontre rente
est ce un baiser quand on sait que 16 et
[Musique]
c'est qu'en fait les gens qui sont venus
ils ont mal calculé ce qui fait que moi
je mange pas semer ses limites en
profite l'un
d'eux passe je passe pas et ans
maximilien on va voir combien ces formes
sociales
chabaks fallait démonter la douve pour
rentrer dedans tu essaie d'enlever la
part de
ses banques à la pendule avait le cul
c'est pire ah oui ça c'est bien aussi tu
fais ton petit propos offensants
[Musique]
il faut dormir pour être tranquille et
avoir la paix va dormir
mesdames et messieurs bonjour
et bienvenue à bord de l'un scandale
airlines la compagnie aérienne de la
tipp scandale appuyé nous indiquer dans
les commentaires la prochaine
destination vers laquelle la team
stendhal devra voyager ne vous
souhaitons une bonne fin de pandémie
[Musique]